[Musique]
jean d'ormesson bonsoir bonsoir ortement
merci il a accepté de jouer à ce jeu un
petit peu cruel du pin kung où vous
allez devoir répondre à une critique par
forcément bienveillants sur votre
dernier elle risquait d'être cruel que
pour lui alors votre dernier roman une
fête une fête en larmes et je vais un
petit peu dire ce qu'il en est de ce
roman vous aimez lire ce que vous en
pensez
à savoir que ce sont les confidences
biographique d'un vieil écrivain plutôt
très connu qui s'appellerait monsieur
jean et qui par là une certaine clara
une journaliste de l'express une jeune
femme et c'est l'occasion pour cet
écrivain de raconter sa vie en quelque
sorte avec quelques digressions
historiques et philosophiques
smith urgences ne serait pas vous par
hasard alors naturellement je peux dire
vous allez que flaubert disait madame
bovary c'est moi et moi je peux dire
monsieur genre c'est moi ce qui nous
intéresse la province temps c'est de
savoir ce que frédéric beigbeder a pensé
de votre roman la bouteille frédéric
beigbeder c'est à la fois un auteur que
l'on connaît bien également ce qu'on
appelle un flingueur chez les critiques
et j'ajouterais que c'est un ami bien
évidemment et alors nous allons regarder
ça critique alors vous connaissez le le
mécanisme vous avez frédéric beigbeder
qui va apparaître à l'écran et vous
pouvez mais couper le sifflet
l'interrompent quand vous le souhaitez
alors mettons en marche voilà on va voir
apparaître d'albi bd bien qu alors c'est
toujours la même chose jandaud sa vie
son oeuvre
la grande élégance de cet homme fut
d'être gâteux très tôt d'où sans doute
une élection précoce a bien eu un gars
très tôt il a raison il a raison parce
que quand j'étais candidat à l'académie
française
quand j'étais candidat je racontais
l'histoire suivante qu'est les deux
académiciens qui se rencontrent et le
premier diot second comment va notre
confrère un thème elodie à moitié gâteux
elle premier dit ah il va mieux alors
vous voyez que je suis assez d'accord
avec eux
bd le problème le problème est de savoir
si à l'académie ont choisi les membres
de l'académie parmi les gâteux ou s'ils
le deviennent parce qu'ils ont été élus
vous avez une idée de la réponse dans un
peu de l'académie française sans brio l
oral a toujours excuser de charmants de
banalités à l'écrit l'enfance est un âge
béni c'est vrai que c'est pas ce qui est
le plus original pourrait prendre mon
avion également s'il n'y avait pas de
progrès nous en serions encore à l'âge
du feu voilà je suis sûr que j'endosse
sera d'accord qu'il a probablement écrit
des choses meilleures
également cette phrase le monde ne cesse
de changer et une cesse de rester là
mais déjà à au progrès c'est ce qui me
frappe vous savez c'est l'air un peu
emprunté on dirait que c'est un peu
embarrassé pour lui 30 a dit très à son
aise mais enfin voyons la suivante un
effet sur tout ce qu'on lui reproche
extraire des phrases loin de nous
l'envient de répéter les vacheries
qu'écrivait bernard frank dans les
années soixante dix nous avons tous eu
de la chance d'avoir un jean d'ormesson
surtout bernard franck bernard pivot
aussi et la france quelqu'un qui
n'arrête pas d'écrire pour dire qu'il
n'a rien écrit un peu solennel oui c'est
un discours d'autres à l'académie les
français aiment jean d'ormesson parce
que c'est un brillant aristocrate qui se
prétend aussi médiocre que or il n'est
pas médiocre il est juste flemmards un
jour mais manon
le dilettante amateur et je remercie
beaucoup à l'aide de me faire passer
pour fait mal parce que si je suis fait
mal c'est que j'ai un peu de talent en
réalité plus travailler énormément elle
vous savez la définition de flaubert sur
une littérature 10% d'inspiration 90%
transpiration pas mal pour un flemmard
quand je regarde mes 33 livres vers un
quotidien quand il en sera peut-être un
charme la nonchalance faut voir ce que
tu es partie de votre charme
la nonchalance je pourrais lui donner
des leçons aux chalands sound est un peu
comme ça est un peu d'eux au mieux la
les besogneux dans la nonchalance volet
bella alors que vous êtes plutôt
aristocratique de lannouchen roanne 85
donc si l'on fait jean dont c'est le
bonheur est ce qu'on peut à la fois être
heureux et être écrivain
je ne sais pas avoir une vie agréable et
une oeuvre légère et 100 fois préférable
sacrifice sur l'autel de la postérité
prescription penser qu'amd rappelé qu'
il ya des écrivains qui peuvent à la
fois être apparemment léger et
jouer un rôle dans la littérature comme
la fontaine par exemple ou en musique
comparez pas lui bien sûr mozart qui est
évidemment le rêve pour tout écrivain
est ce que vous aimez qu'on vous appelle
jean do mais il n'y a que les gens qui
ne me connaissent pas qui a fait ça ne
me gêne pas du tout oui mais quand
quelqu'un dit parle de gens dont je sais
que ce n'est pas ma famille est une
primauté
enfin deux personnes qui me connaît
vraiment m'appelle janvier à la lucidité
de se dire puisque je ne serai pas
proust ni chateaubriand autant viser
paul jean toulet
alors évidemment si visé falkland
toullec est un très très grand écrivain
ce serait déjà très très bien mes bd oui
et même pour moi mais si c'est encore
trop cette histoire d'attentât d'une
jeune journaliste qui débarque chez un
écrivain et les coudes cela monte
pendant toute une journée
comme d'habitude l'écrivain le désespoir
enthousiasme que se lamenter je crois
que j'étais un écrivain du bonheur et
voilà que je vous la man uvre un peu de
cohérence peut-être là dedans
rien n'est plus triste pour un auto
génère que se confier à une jeune
peyronnel qui ne comprend pas le quart
du tiers de ce qu'il raconte
alors ça c'est évidemment je voudrais
prendre la défense de clark duke la rue
je me de ventes
clara n'est pas meilleur journaliste que
beigbeder mais c'est peut-être sa mère
de clara connaît tous les clara a lu mon
ami nan clara à l'ubu la hausse elle
sait qu'ils disent
elle allume arabe salariaux mais fait je
regrette beaucoup de ne pas avoir fait
des gants face de moi j'aurais à voir si
c'est qui est du neez sylla lui madame
salariaux et s'il en connaît autant que
clara mais ce n'est pas la personne est
là pourquoi il ne faut pas vieillir à
partir d'un certain âge on manque
d'interlocuteurs ça c'est un problème
puisque j'ai frédéric qu'enfin soit
enfin quand lara et polis et qu'en plus
il s'est tapé sa grand mère il invente
sa vie pour la distraire et un peu la
drague et voilà sa vie jean d'ormesson
l'avait raconté très souvent dans du
côté de chez jean au revoir et merci
le vagabond qui passe sous une ombrelle
trouver garçons de quoi écrire la douane
de mer le rapport gabriel voyez comment
dans ce tout ça est vrai sur les toits
voyez comment dans ce canard au mans où
j'apparais relativement peu alors là la
formation non mais c'est pas grave on
peut pas être soumis aux pensions
c'était bien tous et tous ces livres que
je viens de citer raconte exactement la
même chose qu'une fête en larmes
c'est un tout petit peu répétitif en
même temps je crois que être un écrivain
vous savez très bien comme moi c'est
avoir les obsessions doux et être un
écrivain c'est écrire toujours la même
chose
c'est ce qu'on appelle un style canton
la pâte style je fais allusion à
personne quand on n'a pas de si l'on
peut écrire n'importe quoi mais coton un
style quand on écrit les livres qu'on
reconnaît aussitôt c'est évident que on
écrit toujours la même chose
chateaubriand doit écrire que du
chateaubriand mauriac ne peut écrire que
du mot rien tout l'est ne peut être que
les to lay et journaliste en revanche
ils peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent
c'est ce que font tous les grands
écrivains modiano se répète ou el bec se
répète je me répète alors est ce qui est
de frappant avec fellag bd que j'aime
beaucoup encore une fois et petite amie
à moi c'est que de temps en temps il dit
des choses vraies il dit par exemple que
je suis un grand écrivain
c'est bien possible
alors ces mails et tout le temps à des
choses fausses il dit que lui aussi est
un écrivain et ça vraiment c'est très
improbable
jean d'ormesson se répète voilà nous
sommes tous de grands jets négateurs non
nous sommes peut-être décroché ni
gâteuse mais on peut dissocier les
choses et être uniquement un grand génie
ou être uniquement gâteux chiffré l'oeil
il aura une aubaine ou si la note
diffusée alors évidemment c'est vrai que
vous savez comparaison coupe
définitivement
c'est vrai que c'est très difficile de
comparer les écrivains est évident que
est évident que frais de beigbeder
n'écrira pas ce que j'écris c'est clair
et que moi je m'en voudrais décrire ce
qu'écrit frédéric bellay alors chacun
pour soi et chacun a évidemment le droit
de dire ce qu'ils pensent des livres des
autres et d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé ça se
critique du pour moi c'est une
déclaration d'amour et les miens et je
crains pour moi d'amour voilée parce que
je lui ai répondu bien de chalon et je
voudrais qu'on nous en donne est ce qui
vous est arrivé d'être meurtri blessé
vendredi de critiquer
vous savez pas pour moi oui je ne sais
pas je me rappelle une certaine critique
de rivaliser
oui sur certains personnages sur
certains de décrivent actions maintenant
ses confrères à l'académie était
vraiment très très bien très amusante
mais rinaldi n'est pas la preuve qu'on
peut aller à l'académie en étant méchant
mais est-ce qu'on peut aller à
l'académie si on est pas mais ce bois là
n'est pas la question si vous aviez une
dernière chose à dire à frédéric
beigbeder qu'est ce que vous lui diriez
ci s'il était là ce soir dans la dans la
salle gré en silence en tout cas merci
beaucoup jean d'ormesson alors nous
avons parlé de votre dernier roman une
fête en larmes et je conseille à tout le
monde de se faire sa propre idée est de
le lire
en tout cas merci beaucoup et j'espère
que frédéric beigbeder a bien reçu la
leçon
oh c'est pas une leçon sur les
déclarations amicales et on devrait
finir sa otan avaient enfin j'espère
j'espère d'ailleurs à la contacter
d'invitation vous pouvez le transmettre
à frédéric en france lol tu vois
absolument pas
[Musique]